you're very funny and I'm curious if
that intimidates men when you're dating
them do you find that it that some men
find it a little like oh my god I she's
so funny I'm not sure that I can partner
up with this woman I didn't think that
was the case but I recently read an
article my friend another female comic
sent me an article called why men don't
like funny women and it was more
devastating than most climate change
reports to me because there's science
that backs it up and really it was from
I forget the public I think was from the
Atlantic Ocean it was a waterlogged
Seventeen magazine it was from it was
from the Atlantic and I actually checked
the research on it because I brought it
into my therapists office to cry about
it being like do you see what I'm
talking about like men don't like funny
women and she was like let me check that
and she got back to me about it she like
checked the research and she's like yeah
this isn't looking good for you like we
should look into women because here's
what they found and this is true so men
and women look for the same thing in the
opposite sex they say looks first and
then sense of humor second but the the
thing is men and women to find sense of
humor differently in the opposite sex
men women to find sense if you were in a
man is a man who makes them laugh and
men to find sense of humor in a woman as
a woman who laughs at their jokes so
that's
really yes and I what are you brewing
that you booing that theory I've known
it forever I love cackling at a hot guy
with a pun like and make it look like
your orgasm and kind of remind them of
that like it's all just science really
do you really you really think that's
true I really think it's true Conan
because it makes sense like a funny
woman is just a yappy broad and I'm one
of the happiest broads going and I think
it just guys are just kind of like they
don't meet it that like it's it's
biological because I think that um I
don't know I think men when they're on
stage especially male comedians clean up
in the woman department when guys who
are funny because we were tried to do a
guy with the sense of humor especially a
guy who stands on stage commanding the
attention of an audience controlling
their emotions
I think our cavewoman brain is just kind
of like he's the tribe leader like I he
will protect me during war time and
famine and then which no comedian would
ever saw we are horrible people it's
such a disparity between what they're
putting out there and what what they
really are yes true I mean that actually
reminds me of I saw the movie San
Andreas where like the rock is saving
its family the entire time and I'm like
I need to find a man who will rescue me
when the like a catastrophic weather
event happens like that's the only way
to survive one of those is to be married
to the rock and so and I'm thinking
about I really do want a man that I can
just wait and he'll come and get me cuz
my dad used to be that guy for me but
now he he lives in st. Louis I'm in New
York it's gonna take him a while to get
to me also I'm bumped down on his list
he has grandkids now still ahead of my
mom I fought for that position I kissed
my dad on the lips until I was 26 so I
my dad is backstage Wow yeah yeah one
day I was like dad I can't do this
anymore and he's like we kissed on the
lips in this family I'm like then why
haven't you kissed mom in a decade but
point was is that I'm thinking like I
need a guy like the rock and then I'm
like I don't know that the rock could do
what he did in that movie I just
pictured the rock like an earthquake
happening and he just he'll probably
just sprint out of his mansion with his
like awards and his protein powders and
maybe Kevin Hart under one I got the
awards I got the cars full of chicken
breasts so I don't know I've did I do
feel though that when men watch a woman
kind of just like I'm on stage with a
microphone I'm good at comedy and that
doesn't take away from it it just isn't
arousing to men to have a woman be like
my itches or you know whatever in some
communities on reddit think my special
was about but it does it Conan
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry this happens
every time and that's me it doesn't but
that's what men kind of hear when I'm
talking I feel like and it's not what I
was hearing